well I don't think you can be
pessimistic but I think that there are
some pesta meza mystic trends that I
don't like and one of them is the lack
of resiliency in our political system
that that does worry me a lot and we if
we continue down that road we will not
have the best and brightest going into
politics and that's harmful for America
on the other hand I think we're going to
have a more educated world than we did
before I think the Internet offers great
possibilities for democratizing
education we get more people learning
more things so you have to be optimistic
i mean i think we have some serious
challenges from the in global
environment to wage and income
inequality which exists to disease
various diseases and energy and other
kinds of things but i'm not sure there's
anything that can't be dealt with if our
political systems are resilient enough
to deal with them